i've got my briefcase computer
calculator
pen paper coffee cup and eternal
dedication to the corporation
oh boy we are in that part of youtube
again
[Music]
hello internet welcome to film theory
blowing the toupee off your favorite
creepy parts of youtube and today we're
looking at the weird
lovable man slash robot slash astronaut
slash little tau lovin
dad welcome to ova
you may call me dead primary tasks
propagate internet simulation
spread rhythmic addictions
share bodily floss am i doing a good job
dad's channel has been on youtube for
two years now and in that amount of time
he's
really done it all he sings he dances he
plays minecraft he
somehow parties with marshmallow and
jamie foxx he hosts a drama show where
he talks about all the cults that are
out to get him who are you working with
are you in the dark party and he pledges
his undying allegiance to the server
that'll bring us eternal happiness you
know all the typical youtuber stuff and
that's kind
of the point of the channel dad's
primary objective is to become the
number one youtuber
sorry to be the quote best youtuber pop
singer influencer in the universes
even sending out a warning shot to
pewdiepie that's a felix the cat on a
pie in case you missed the reference now
you're probably asking yourself why i'm
making a theory about a man who
seems to be going through a midlife
crisis well my fellow theorists there's
a lot more going on under those khakis
than you might think
the dad feels channel is one of the
longest most committed and well-produced
args out there
complete with hidden codes secret
channels and live events full of lore
reveals heck dad even appears on other
channels scott the waz inside of mind
nightmind night docs just to name a few
sometimes indoctrinating them
sometimes leaving creepy comments or
just leaving behind spectrogram codes
that obnoxious series of sounds by the
way actually translates to this a dad
bot
boot up sequence dad even recently
called me out but then
immediately deleted the video you
cowards you and cheryl and your server
summoned me out of my slumber
tempting me with frame by frame lore
secrets only to immediately dial it all
back well there was no need i've been
watching you for a while now
dad and i know your game today i plan to
expose the world or
at least our little corner of youtube to
the elaborate game that you've crafted
there is a lot to it i mean look no
further than the multi-hour videos other
channels have uploaded trying to talk
about all the facets of this mystery but
today i'm not going to cover it all
just the main parts to get you all
acquainted with the dad's story as well
as some of the key clues that have been
dropped along the way
so what is the dad feels mystery what's
hiding behind that beautiful receded
hairline consider
this video your starter's guide to one
of the most interesting channels on
youtube
across all the universes the story
begins with the man behind the character
nathan barnett starting his own channel
way back in 2006 he's been on the
platform for a
long time nathan is an actor and
comedian known for his physical comedy
his dancing and his dedication to
staying in character and when i say that
he's dedicated to staying in character
i mean he is dedicated he's been thrown
out of comic-con for climbing the
building in character he's been thrown
out of comic-con for crashing a peter
jackson and james cameron panel
in character there was even a time when
he shattered his foot jumping off a
14-foot ledge and continued the show in
character for another 45 minutes before
rushing off to the hospital true story i
was there for that last one both
nathan's character
a retro gaming nerd named keith apache
and game theory were early featured
shows on a website called
screwattack.com way before
youtube series were a thing and so we
were both featured guests at their
convention while nathan was busy
breaking his feet jumping off of
buildings i was actually two doors over
hanging out with fans of the show
but hey that's just a theory
a game theory thanks for recording this
and uploading it to youtube
i was sitting on that table talking to
everyone for like six hours that day
we've been arm wrestled finish
man that was only six years ago but when
i got done hanging out with everyone i
remember in the guest green room hearing
about the foot shattering incident and
that was actually the last time our
paths almost crossed until today you see
one of nathan's most recent characters
is a man known as dad
in the series called dad feels it
started as the character dad
feeling different emotions and
performing dances associated with each
feeling pretty
simple or at least it was until nathan
uploaded a video on his channel on
january 1st 2019 titled goodbye youtube
i unfortunately am going to just kind of
end my youtube
and wrap it up at first it seems like
nathan is quitting his beloved dream job
but if you watch
all the way through to the end we
actually see a familiar face
dad
following the link at the end leads to a
video with no title and nathan crouching
down on camera
whispering
my feeling is near my
feet we've survived unisonness and fnaf
this ain't our first time at the rodeo
friends
nathan is talking backwards he's coming
they released him
don't let them find me
please someone is coming after nathan
huh is it
dad or is it someone else notice that
nathan specifically says
they released him looking down into the
comment section i know it's dangerous
but don't worry i'll hold your hand we
find a pinned comment left by dad on the
video
sending us to a whole catalog of uploads
which in their entirety
tell us the story of dad in three
separate acts act one sets up our main
characters there's dad who works at
company eats food
idolizes the great deals made available
at true value hardware and longs to get
a kiss from his loving wife
named wife we later learned that her
name is cheryl along with their daughter
named daughter the three lived together
as a happy family in town
usa yeah it's a pretty obvious that this
is meant to be a robotic simulation of
your typical everyday family if i had to
describe the atmosphere of these early
videos it's a pretty similar setup to
the other weirdly robotic internet
personality poppy even down to her
robotic voice except here
everyone speaks telepathically for
reasons
daughter you know the rule you're not
allowed to have boys come over until you
reach a certain yes
griffin can come over just like poppy in
the early phases was kind of an ai
designed to be a singer
influencer by the illuminati dad is a
robot living in some computerized family
situation
but not quite you see dad's story goes
way
deeper across act 1 we learn that this
is not your typical happy
robotic telepathic family through some
not-so-subtle wood imagery we learned
that
wife is in love with the neighbor malvin
wait is that a typo malvin with an
a nope it is definitely malvin ew
what a dumb name dad meanwhile appears
to be getting feelings for wife's friend
diane
so much so that he even made a song
about her her perfume
lingers on dad's fingers
when exchanging greetings is his
sniffing cheating
well dad i don't think so but i do think
making an entire song and music video
about it may raise some suspicions with
wife
oh and uh he also has a daughter with
diane from them sniffing each other
because scent is the most powerful human
emotion like i said there's a lot of
stuff going on here but that is a whole
other rabbit hole that we're not going
to go down right now so then is that it
the whole dad story is just a simulation
of a family living inside a computer
with some family drama no
if that was it i probably wouldn't be
covering it you see all that setup is
small potatoes for the
bigger story that's happening here
throughout these videos we occasionally
see a mysterious man in black clothes
with a youtube logo on his chest
he never really does anything he just
kind of stands there watching like dad
is some kind of prisoner or pet making
things even stranger are the flashes of
memories that randomly appear when dad
bot suffers from temporary glitches
and it's worth pointing out that this is
all happening in the middle of a four
hour solo dance party at the beach that
is commitment to the bit but what is the
bit here
what's the story that's trying to be
told well to understand let's
turn back to the music videos which are
often the best places to find lore
in the series you see all the music
videos keep referencing the
same thing outer space they dream of the
older days
days spent under kepler race some things
that make that feel good are can of food
[Music]
so what is kepler-22b well kepler-22b is
the first planet confirmed by nasa to
exist in a habitable zone of a sun-like
star
i.e a planet that could feasibly act
just like earth it's located about 620
light years from earth in fact and these
are our first indications that dad feels
is actually about something much bigger
outer space which gets confirmed at the
start of act two when we catch our first
glimpse of an astronaut stranded in the
middle of a desert and man talk about
that production value did i not tell you
that this is like one of the most
committed bits of all time
didn't expect that one so what connects
a robotic dad
an unconscious astronaut in the desert
and the men in black from youtube
well obviously it's a kidnapping plot in
another music video titled dad feels
golden we see a name flash up briefly
captain andenril this is our astronaut
via various clues sprinkled throughout
act 2 we learned that anden was a pilot
working for a company
named dad distant aerospace destinations
the clues
seem to suggest that he was from the
planet kepler-22b and was married to a
woman named ella which is who we're
seeing in those flashes of memory when
dadbot starts glitching out he had a
mission to the planet cfb0403 but
something happens
resulting in anden and his lieutenant
emily crashing onto earth so
how does dadbot and youtube factor into
anden's outer space adventures well as
the snippets of memory peeking through
dadbot's glitches may have hinted and
din
is dead at various points throughout the
series we see dad
eating food that isn't well food with a
capital f-o-o-d
and each time he does he snaps out of
the dad-bot persona appearing confused
until someone rushes onto the scene to
force-feed him the red food and get him
back under control
hey who are you stop wait stop did i
order these it appears that dad
isn't actually a robot but rather a
human being controlled by whatever's
inside that can of food this is further
solidified by moments like this
dad is already growing in which dad is
using sign language to communicate that
he needs help but this just leaves us
with even more questions like why is
youtube involved and what's the goal of
the dad program well it's established
that dad is housed in the facility
basically
underground at the youtube space in l.a
and that wife cheryl who works at the
facility kidnapped anden to run
experiments on him i need a favor
i've kidnapped someone and i need you to
help me keep him sedated so i can
continue my quantum physics research
based on their conversation wife and
neighbor got divorced when they lost
their daughter
melvin you know i still love you we
died when we lost her so it's my guess
that cheryl's overarching goal in all
this is to find a way to get her
daughter back
we learn from and in the livestream that
earth technology is far
behind what kepler-22b had oh this
planet
you guys you probably still use fax
machines and in various pinned comments
we see dadbot alluding to the fact that
she lost her children
and she's calling to them so i would
guess that she's using anden and the
dadbot program to either
unlock kepler's secret quantum
technology or to create a perfect
recreation of the loved ones that she's
lost
basically she's both william afton from
fnaf and kingpin from
into the spiderverse so that's our story
or at least a small portion of it all of
this is without even mentioning the
multiple versions of dad bots running
around killing each other his secret
gaming channel the server's goal and all
of this their malfunctioning daughter
and her boyfriend griffin and nathan
barnett himself the serious creator
who's also been playing a role in the
whole thing
claiming on his personal channels and
socials that he's gotten his identity
stolen even to the point of contacting
lawyers about it
nathan throughout the lord of the story
gets body swapped out with anden in the
desert and in the process
infected with a space fungus off of and
in suit that gives rise to human
which after sucking his subscribers dry
of donations his words in a bunch of
deleted live streams and not mine was
recently passed on to a new host named
mila who's being supervised by
some guy named like the game master
something like that anyway as you can
tell there is a lot
even as i write this act 3 is about to
conclude which i expect is going to
bring
even more to the table like i said this
is a complicated but
really really fun and a huge arg
production that's been going strong for
the last two years
it's also clear in the lore of the
series that the dad bot program gains
power as he gains subscribers he went
quantum last year when he crossed a
hundred thousand and now he's aiming to
go
eternal when he crosses five hundred
thousand i don't know exactly what that
means but each time he gets a big
subscriber leap the lore for this thing
tends to get
real interesting so hey if you think
small independent youtube productions
like this are cool and want to support
one that's been working
really hard for the better part of two
years give them a sub and in the process
effect how this story is going to play
out seriously this
is a channel that really plays along
with the audience so be a part of the
mystery and adventure over there
but hey that's just a knock at the door
huh hmm
interesting food
[Music]
foreign